[Music]
thank you
well hello everyone Welcome to our
program I'd like to know as you know
this is a question and answer program
where you send us your questions and on
the air we answer the questions if there
is such a thing uh we're glad that you
decide to join us today this is one of
our favorite programs uh let me give you
the address of where you can send us
your questions it's an electronic
address you'll see it on the screen TV
at some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org I have with me my good friend C.A
Murray it's always a delight to work
with him he loves the study of the Bible
and he also loves to preach like I do
and so CA it's a wonderful thing to have
you here good to be here always good to
study the word of God with you to sit at
your feet and then to share the word
with you my pleasure my blessing well we
actually sit at each other's feet
but anyway
a question that we did not answer there
were two questions and we only answered
one so let's have a word of prayer and
then we'll go to the maybe you can read
the second question okay could you add
prayer for us we'll do
gracious father again we praise you and
thank you for your word which is a lamp
unto our feet a light unto our path we
thank you Father that your word can be
studied can be understood and that when
we do so when we come to you in prayer
and in faith and humility you will show
us your will and your way through the
power of your word so father lift up
your name this day help us to understand
the your will as we open your word and
may we and those who sit and hear what
we have to say be blessed and we thank
you in Jesus name amen amen
alrighty this is from Dr Albert Frank
Cox and before I go into this question
on Lou Sabbath
um he adds here incidentally Pastor Bohr
your ministry was very instrumental to
me becoming a Seventh-Day Adventist I
went through your Bible series which at
the time uh he thinks there's about 39
studies but if it's the one that we're
thinking of it's actually a little
longer than that it really gave me a
solid grounding so praise be to God and
I am still going after 20 plus years on
as a bonus he says you do not look any a
day older
amen and amen thank you so much Dr Cox
you made my day
all right Pastor the question is on uh
what he calls the deception of the lunar
Sabbath I happen to know that you have a
very thorough and very well done
documented study on the lunar Sabbath uh
that I heard a portion of just a little
bit ago so walk us through a little bit
of that and maybe we can just send in
the materials if he wants to get a
thorough understanding okay Dr Cox uh I
promise to send to your email that you
that you included in your question uh
the studies that I've done on the lunar
Sabbath idea actually they go according
to a what they call a loony solar
calendar
and basically they call it Looney
because they believe that the first day
of the new moon the Crescent Moon uh is
the is the weekly Sabbath and then the
8th the 15th the 22nd and the 29th of
the month are the succeeding sabbaths
the problem with uh Reckoning uh the
Sabbath according to uh the Crescent
Moon is that sometimes the Crescent Moon
cannot be seen particularly in biblical
times and secondly uh that would mean
that the Sabbath falls on a different
day of the week uh every week you can
imagine the nightmare of holding down
unemployment if you if you have to tell
your boss well my Sabbath falls on
Monday this week and then the following
week it falls on Wednesday it would be a
nightmare God does not make things
complicated for us
the moon has nothing to do with the
observance of the Sabbath it does have
to do with the observance of the
festivals of the Hebrew Festival yes but
the Sabbath is reckoned by the Sun
and I just like to read maybe a few
statements here from the spirit of
Prophecy where Ellen White discusses uh
how the Sabbath is reckoned the first
quotation is in Patriots and Prophets
page 111
where she states like the Sabbath the
weak originated at creation
and it had has been preserved and
brought down to us through Bible History
in other words the weekly cycle has
never been broken yes so the Sabbath
today is the same Sabbath of creation
she continues God himself measured off
the first week
as a sample for successive weeks to the
close of time like every other it
consisted of seven literal days six days
were employed in the work of creation
upon the seventh God rested and he then
blessed this day and set it apart as a
day of rest for man so the Sabbath that
is the same Sabbath of creation because
the weekly cycle has never been broken
yes in another place Ellen White wrote
in testimonies to ministers 135 God
speaks to the Human family in a language
they can comprehend he does not leave
the matter so indefinite that human
beings can handle it according to their
theories when the Lord declares that
this is critically important when the
Lord declares that he made the world in
six days and rested on the seventh he
means the day of 24 hours which he has
marked off by the rising and setting of
the Sun
so in other words the days are reckoned
by the Sun and therefore the weak yes is
reckoned by the days that are reckoned
by the sun uh one further quotation
manuscript releases volume three page
253 God made his Sabbath for a round
world
and when the seventh day comes to us in
that round World
controlled by the Sun that rules the day
it is the time in all countries and
lands to observe the sabbath in the
countries where there is no sunset for
months and again no Sunrise for months
the period of time will be calculated by
the records kept you know as Adventists
we've been critical of the papacy
because it thought it could change God's
law uh from keeping the Sabbath to
keeping Sunday but the lunar Sabbath
idea is telling us also to keep a
counterfeit Sabbath because it's not The
Seventh-Day Sabbath so it's the same
principle if we keep the lunar Sabbath
we're really not keeping the Sabbath of
the Lord thy God yes it's an idolater
Sabbath and it's just as erroneous as
keeping Sunday or any other false day
that's right it's not the right day and
uh you know I could go into the
presentation that I'm that I made at our
recent anchor School of Theology in
Dallas
uh but that would be a duplication
because I already did it and we don't
have an hour to do it right now so uh Dr
Cox I will be glad to send this to you
uh to the same email address that you
gave us when you sent us the question
and study it through uh the study that I
gave makes it absolutely clear without a
shadow of a doubt that the lunar Sabbath
is a deception that the lunar Sabbath is
not based on the solid word of God
having sat through that
um presentation I concur how hard it's a
this deception and a distraction that is
unnecessary in these last days just
something for men to occupy their time
and wonder about when the the true
Sabbath is there explained beautifully
in the word of God over and over again
and verified by The Seventh-Day week
evening and morning each day actually
I'll send Dr Cox two studies that I did
on this issue and there's probably I
would say between 20 and 25 pages of
material and I think that it will answer
the question uh very well without a
shadow of a doubt amen
further without any doubt
all right Pastor let's see
um
Alexander
nakamsi
is that the next one or is it I have uh
Emmanuel oladele
okay then I just got my okay
here we go
from Nigeria
[Music]
nope I've got Alex oh
that's a short question
Alexander no I've got I've got a
different a different batch here well
let me let me read it okay and then
while you while you search in your notes
there uh once again I'm going to
reiterate that uh you know the reason
why we have to look uh at what we have
written on this is because we don't uh
do this program live
because when you do a program live a lot
of uh verses and a lot of quotations
from the spirit of Prophecy come to mind
but we don't have access to them because
the program is live whereas when the pr
when the questions are sent in advance
we have a chance to look for all of the
answers the Bible verses and the
quotations from the spirit of Prophecy
did you find it there I did okay
uh pastor and one of your messages you
said Pharisees and Sadducees created
more than a thousand laws and enforced
them on Israelite purposely
um
for them to be able to keep the Sabbath
for Israel to be able to kill the
Sabbath you said when Jesus came he
abolished those laws please sir what are
those one hundred thousand ten what are
those one thousand plus laws and where
can we find them in the Bible uh and
in another of your messages you talked
about ceremonial laws what are they and
where do you get them in the Bible okay
what I actually said was that Jesus uh
brought the ceremonial laws to an end
not the traditions of the elders the
traditions of the elders were never part
of God's will right
um he asked about more than a thousand
laws that's actually one thousand six
hundred and twenty one I have this book
called code of Jewish law and it was
actually compiled by Rabbi Solomon
gansfried
and if I can just um indulge here a
little bit and read a few of those laws
um you know there some of them are
somewhat ridiculous uh for example it is
forbidden to wipe anything with a sponge
that has no handle
okay okay uh it is forbidden to spit in
a place where the wind will scatter the
saliva these are these are things
regarding Sabbath observance
um salads made of lettuce cucumbers or
onions may be salted immediately before
the meal because oil and vinegar are
generally added immediately which weaken
the effect of the salt
[Laughter]
here's another one Pepper or salt needed
for seasoning food maybe crust with the
handle of a knife or in any other
convenient way but may not be crushed in
a mortar
interesting now what is there there's
Bunches of these of these you know if a
person had a prosthetic leg uh you know
wooden leg uh they would have to take it
all up on Sabbath because they couldn't
bear a burden on the Sabbath those were
the types of laws where do you find
those laws in the Bible yeah absolutely
nowhere by the way this big book not
only deals with Sabbath laws it deals
with other laws it became practically
impossible to keep the Sabbath in the
days of Christ because how are you going
to memorize all of the details that you
find in this book it's it's virtually
impossible uh to to keep the Sabbath
um here's another one wet mud on a
garment may be scraped off with a
fingernail or with a knife
but not when it is dry for it is then
equivalent to the act of grinding
[Laughter]
you know I could I could read many many
more but I think that the point is made
perhaps it'd be a good idea to read mark
seven if you would look up Mark 7 CA and
read verses 5 to 13
and we'll see that those laws they were
not nailed to the cross because they
weren't laws of God in the first place
correct uh Mark chapter 7 and verses 5
to 13 this has to do with uh you know
with the with Cora the Corbin Corbin uh
the practice of Corbin so let's read uh
beginning verse 5 through verse 13. all
right I'm reading from the new King
James then the Pharisees and scribes
asked him
why do your disciples not walk according
to the tradition of the elders but eat
bread with unwashed hands
he answered and said to them well did
Isaiah prophesy of you Hypocrites as it
is written this people honors me with
their lips but their heart is far from
me and in vain they worship me teaching
as doctrines the Commandments of men
okay all the way through verse 13. okay
for laying aside the Commandments of God
you hold the tradition of men the
washing of pitchers and cups and many
other such things you do
he said to them
All Too Well you reject the Commandment
of God that you may keep your tradition
for Moses said honor your father and
your mother and he who curses father or
mother let him be put to death I'm at
verse 11. but you say if a man says to
his father or mother whatever Prophet
you might have received from me is
Corbin
uh that is a gift to God then you no
longer let him do anything for his
father or his mother making the word of
God of no effect through your tradition
which you have handed down and many such
things you do
so these uh Traditions were the
traditions of men they were never part
of the Bible and so Jesus did not nail
these to the Cross because they were
never part of his plan because I see the
ceremonial law was nailed to the cross
because Jesus fulfilled what was in the
ceremonial law now this mentions just to
give you an example this mentions uh the
practice of Corbin
that means gift of gift to God or uh
yeah gift to God and so carbon basically
was that children while they were alive
could dedicate everything they had to
the Lord but then they could use it the
rest of their lives and it became part
of the temple at the end right and so
um if the parents were in need they
would say to their children help us the
children would say sorry we can't
because it's Corbin it's dedicated to
God we can't give it to you and so they
were violating a commandment of the
Bible yes that says honor your father
and your mother to keep the tradition of
men which was Corbin which contradicted
yes the Commandment of God and so
basically
there were over a thousand 1 621 laws
and if people would have to be phds to
be able to live in harmony with all of
them
that's amazing and and the Jewish
Community has had this tradition of
adding to the word of God in New York
for many years the grand rebbe was
Monica schneerson
and every year he would codify and write
down additional things that the Jewish
community in New York the Hasidic
Community the very conservative Jews
were supposed to do this year you have
to do so many works of Charity or give
alms or do this kind of thing along with
all the other things so they would
routinely add stuff this was not in the
Bible it was it was a tradition of men
that had gone on so long they accepted
it as biblical but it was not it was it
was a man-made tradition and if I might
say
the reason why much of the Protestant
World rejects the Sabbath
is because they're looking at the
Sabbath
as the rabbis did in other words Jesus
did not
condemn the Sabbath
he condemned the way in which the Jews
of his day kept the sound yes you know
Christians say oh that Sabbath that
Seventh-day Adventist Sabbath that's a
great big yoke of bondage but really
they're thinking about the Sabbath in
the days of Christ being a yoke of
bondage upon the populace yes but the
Sabbath of the Pharisees is not the
Sabbath of the Lord amen the Sabbath of
the Lord does not have all of the
regulations in fact the Bible makes very
few
gives us very few details about what is
allowed and what is not allowed on
Sabbath uh you know it says you know
should not buy or sell
um it mentions just one or two others
other than that it expresses itself in
principles yes withdraw your foot from
during your will on my holy Sabbath day
and don't speak your words but speak my
words and uh and so it's left to the
individual to apply the principles and
in conscience to say
is this really focused on God on Sabbath
or isn't it and we have to be sincere
with ourselves yes and apply the
principle and uh and then just do on the
basis of the principle yes um
I refuse to make lists you know some
people use they use the last me ah can I
go swimming and Sabbath can I cook on
Sabbath you know can I take a bath on
Sabbath I say listen I don't make lists
of things that you can and can do you
have the principles in the Bible be
sincere and ask the Lord in prayer to
help you apply them correctly and then
you'll be on the right track you know I
I so appreciate that
um the Bible does not lock down what you
can and cannot do
um you quoted Isaiah 58 13 and 14 if
thou Turner was I for the front of the
Sabbath from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day that's a very broad category a
lot of things can fit under there nicely
to give you an idea of what is good to
do on the Sabbath the Lord gives us the
indication that it's good to help people
on the Sabbath it's good thing it's a
good thing to lift the load of Humanity
on the Sabbath
um
there's a lot of things you can do that
that separates you from the work of day
week and allow you to be a blessing to
yourself and to others and to the
kingdom of God on the Sabbath even if
some of those things occasion some some
activities some work activities that you
would not do during the week to lift the
load from somebody else yeah yeah and uh
you know we live in a different world
than those who lived in the times of
Christ or even the times of Ellen White
yes you know Ellen White says that baths
should be taken before the Sabbath
begins right at that time you know bats
were a major ordeal major I mean you had
to get the wood and you had to light the
fire and then you had to heat the water
yes and then you had to let the water
cool down and it was it was just a huge
process that's why they didn't think to
be honest they didn't take very many
baths back then
but today you know it's just a matter of
getting in the shower and turning on the
faucet the same with cooking yeah
cooking was a major Affair now I'm not
saying that what we can do on Sabbath on
Friday we should do on Friday sure sure
to do as least as as least which is
possible on the Sabbath uh but I'm
saying that we need we live in a
different world than in the world of
Ellen White and in the world uh that
existed in the days of Christ and in the
Old Testament I can remember being at
church one Sabbath and a busload of
people came to visit the church I was at
Ephesus and we didn't have enough for
padlocks so the women ran downstairs and
opened up a couple boiling bags and
boiled rice on this app you put in a pot
in your boil it's not that big a deal
um back in the day that would have been
a major task uh but it's not now so
things do change a little bit and of
course you adjust with the times yeah
well the times of Christ you know you
would have been censured for that
would it be better to to let those
people go hungry on the Sabbath rather
than doing that you know uh it was an
act of benevolence they were hungry they
were hungry it's like the disciples
going through the fields on the Sabbath
yes you know they're picking grain and
they're eating the grain that doesn't
mean that you're justified in harvesting
all of your fields on the Sabbath true
you know so so the fair nobody invited
Jesus and the disciples to their home to
eat so you know instead of criticizing
the him yeah they should have said hey
why don't you have lunch with us come
with us yeah yes yes you deal with the
exigency of of the moment
um the thing is Sabbath is to be a
delight and when you burden it with all
of those rules and extra things you know
uh in the 700s 800s the Catholic Church
added the cat the Sabbath fast they made
them fast on Sabbath Feast on Sunday and
in one generation you made the Sabbath
kind of odious you know you got a fast
on a Saturday you can Feast on Sunday
which is why to this day
um I am not a big fan of fasting on
Sabbath I think it's it's in the wrong
spirit I think Sabbath is a celebratory
day it's a blessing day not a day to be
long faced and sort of self-abnegating
and fasting and whatnot there are other
days you can do that let's celebrate the
Sabbath and celebrate the lord of the
city fasting is a sign of Affliction
you're afflicting your soul you know
there's I remember when I was a kid that
they had this violence in the country of
Colombia where my parents went as
missionaries it was violence between
liberal and conservative politicians but
most Protestants were liberals and in
most conservatives were Roman Catholics
so it became a religious War yes and I
remember that there was a Worldwide Day
of fasting in prayer in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church it was Global yes
because of the persecution that that
Seventh-Day Adventists were suffering in
the country of Colombia so there are
special circumstances where a fast on
Sabbath would be appropriate yes but not
Sabbath after Sabbath because I'm among
the Orthodox Jews the Sabbath is not a
day to fast it's a day to Feast the
feast correct and and that doesn't mean
that we do we are to be gluttons when I
say that we're it's supposed to be a day
of a feasting Ellen White even says that
some a special something special yes
should be made to eat on the Sabbath
which sets the Sabbath apart from other
days yeah particularly if you have
children and young people you want to
make that a day that they look forward
to not dread not sitting counting the
hours when the sun is going to go down
you know you're looking looking over the
horizon so the sun's going down so you
can go play but you want to make it a
very special day a day that will be a
blessing to them yeah it's kind of like
uh Amos says the the Jews in the days of
Amos were saying when is that Sun going
to go down slowly we could take our corn
to the market
you know keeping the Sabbath in that in
that way is not really keeping the
Sabbath you know because the Sabbath
really has to be our our special day of
having a relationship with Jesus Christ
yes it's a day to get him to get to know
him better
Etc it's kind of like our anniversary
um you know yeah on our anniversary I
see my wife every day yeah but you know
the anniversary it's it's all day and
all night you know so so uh the Sabbath
is an entire 24 hours where we suspend
everything ours yes and we focus only on
Jesus Christ and on spiritual matters
yeah and if you love me Christ said keep
my Commandments
um if you really love the Lord spending
time in his presence is not a burden you
know to make the Sabbath a burden comes
from the wrong mindset you're if if you
like spending time with your wife you
know you you do that you take her out to
dinner you take her places you take her
to the mall you take other places that's
not a burden for you it's not something
you suck your teeth and say I gotta take
them all no you you do it gladly because
it's part of your commitment to her well
this is part of our commitment how can
keeping Sabbath be a burden if I love
the lord of the Sabbath so strong
relationships
require time precisely you don't form a
strong relationship with someone unless
you spend time with them and so the
Sabbath is meant for us to strengthen
our relationship with Jesus Christ yes
and those people who say oh you know the
Sabbath it's it's drudgery you know we
can't do this we can't do that we can't
do the other thing well I have no desire
to do this and that and the other thing
when I'm with my wife you know I just
enjoy being in her presence and spending
time with her
praise the Lord
um and and you guys you you are a a a
good guy in the kitchen I'm not you know
you can spend time together in the
kitchen and then you can warm it up and
have the fruits of your labor on Sabbath
you know those kinds of things it's it's
it's Pleasant to spend time in the there
are blessings I believe and I know our
time is getting away from us that our
reserved just for the Sabbath amen you
know you can't get them any other day so
if you stay home you stay in your bed
you try to do something else you try to
get on another it's not it's not
amenable to that because those are
Sabbath blessings amen that's right okay
well
time's up
thank you so much for joining us for uh
this program uh remember to send us your
questions to TV at some tv.org we're
glad you decide to join us and I hope
you'll join us next time on this special
program
I'd like to know God bless see you next
time
[Music]